6 zu 0 gegen island
der neustart der schweizer
nationalmannschaft ist geglückt
nach den turbulenzen an der wm in
russland wurden spieler und funktionäre
wieder zur tagesordnung übergehen
die landung des doppels in den schweizer
stuben schwamm drüber
[Applaus]
darf man die schweizer als partner
bezeichnet
er ist ein richtiger schweizer und wie
viele heimaten darf ein mensch in seinem
herzen tragen davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vor dem ehepaar user aus igis liegt eine
aufregende fußballwoche azeroth in der
schweiz und zwischen spielt heute spielt
die schweiz in st gallen gegen island
und morgen schon fliegen die frau saß
mit der nazi nach england regie und ruth
halten ihre nazi eisern die treue
[Musik]
ich glaube lässt
ich bin halt so viel mit wie früher
verändert
[Musik]
die zweite mannschaft dass sie jetzt das
wieder gut macht um mich gute leistung
bot der fußball zeigt dass sie gute
schweizer nazis wo ist das land auto
vertraut und bot die leistung
vollbringen
im st galler kinopark brutzeln schon die
ulmer bratwürste am grill steht vinzenz
lassen schweizer mit albanischen wurzeln
das heißt coach des albanischen
drittliga fußballvereins fc st als
fünfjähriger ist ein die schweiz
gekommen
groß genau
die gerüchte jedenfalls die spitze
getrieben von dem leib an die dorf
gebracht
kollege kreis ganzen schweiz und wir
sind aber im kollegenkreis international
jeden fall bin ich mir auch selber das
ist auch ein schweizer
auch die tüte haben und was sie stört
beschreiben typisch japanisch das
wir hatten schwierige fragen bin ich
schon schweiz oder die organische fans
nahm er ist doch wird das sieht man mal
vom national werk also mal vom wasserbau
emotionaler dass viele monate
wenn der stress sagt dass sie denn
das gras steht und fällt nach wie vor
von der schweizer seite haye
aber in leute mixed-teams
rosa ist fußballer mit leib und seele
im fc porto 2 für die veteranen kickt
hat man sich über die doppeladler
querelen geärgert dass sie diese witze
geräteträger die welt sie auch mit
behinderungen und deren karriere vor
spannend dass sich alle zusammen
wir können ja ich machen wollte
das ist schon muslime bitte übernehmen
wenn ich im prinzip nicht relevant und
situationen ein in der schweiz selber zu
moderiert die 4
die hand hält
unsere andere nationen mit denen wir die
situation vor ort das sind genau
genommen haben sind sorgen ausschwitzen
die termine nationalen erfolgen müssen
aufwachsen zwar hätten ihre sprache die
bösen schweizer albaner egal
heute gilt alle gegen island
[Applaus]
bislang ist
stolze sich freuen
schon da
[Applaus]
die hat sie nun spiel ist luke mal so
hoch ist
[Musik]
ich denke statik einfach cool da ich
super zweite paar taktische faktisch
ändere ich sehe ja es ist wahr
mit dem speed des römers zum mitglied
und spielfreudig
tags darauf am flughafen zürich rote
unterhose reisen mit der schweizer nazi
zum testspiel nach england
nein nein
[Musik]
ihre ferien gleichen diffuses mit dem
spielplan der nazi ab
[Musik]
die kommission
kritik eindeutig
[Musik]
die welt die fußballfans live
nationalmannschaft hier spricht ihr
erster offizier mit einigen
informationen aus dem kombi england
haben ein kleinbürger
das heißt für uns die land umgehen
bei der gepäckausgabe in birmingham
warten ruth und rief hurra und die
anderen fans vergeblich auf die
schweizer spieler
das ist ja abschied schon noch nicht
journalist juristen genau und das paar
fans oder aber ich weiß nicht was das
für die taktik ist kranich kommunikation
gestalter herkommt und eine community
von birmingham aus geht es im bus nach
leicester
[Musik]
lester ist eine von 24 destinationen die
rosa im schlepptau der nazi schon
bereist hat
[Musik]
kronen nationalmannschaft das ist ja
auch mit der grund würde damit trojaner
womöglich normalerweise gar nicht
dank automatischer und
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nix neues
zur gleichen zeit im altehrwürdigen st
galler espenmoos in fünf minuten ist
anpfiff zum spiel fc besa gegen den fc
gossau
es geht um viel der fc besa will den
aufstieg in die zweite liga ich weiß ich
nicht aber was haltet ihr von dem
doppeladler diskussion können wahlkreis
alle kommt wollen nicht dass mir deine
zeige dass er dort chef sind dass man
dort die heime sind dass mir die erste
zweikampf grün hat dass mir der zweite
und der spannend wenn man das schlafen
im zelt wie so dass die irgendeinem
punkt mitnehmen
also jungs im endspiel alles gut ja ok
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch doch
so erzeugt worden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so langsam macht
[Musik]
da ist sie die sprichwörtliche
heißblütig kite in der vergangenheit
hatte sich der verein damit schon
probleme eingehandelt und der
doppeladler jeder hat innensenator die
jubler gespielt viel spiele wie die
afrikaner die kinos oder sie es nur jede
depression doppel europa die füße
einfach nationen symbol und wie findet
sie das der bank sagte dow jones der
verband der schütze die dass sie nicht
hier spielen für diese verband
entschuldige mich war das überhaupt eine
million gebraucht über quasi die jungs
sollen fußballspiele das uns all die
ausländer wollen der schweiz leben das
uns stolz machen müssen stolz national
ensembles mehr
[Applaus]
stand heute wo man nicht eine villa mit
2 0 über wo nötig sie werden von mir
definitiv totalschaden stellen richtig
schlecht doch immer dabei erleben
aber jungs qualität wenn man dort
überall helfen und die vom balkan gebe
doch jeder dass jede frist oder
wahlhebel hin und her spielen jetzt mir
das ja der glaube dass mir zwei bessere
zweite hat sie machen ihren glauben weiß
ja nie wieder voll überzeuge aber ich
weiß nicht jeder selber glauben 2 zu 0
für den fc gossau in der pause es
bleiben 45 minuten um das blatt zu
wenden
[Musik]
von den schul helden in die pubs von
leicester ein zwischenhalt um auch
anderen fans der reisegruppe den puls zu
fühlen
[Musik]
sagen und kann diese drogen oder
visionen wir so sympathisch
[Musik]
es ist die stunde
die dinge sind also fast 30 grad ist die
heutige jugend auf die antwort sehen
aber wer zum beispiel
durch das 2
der doppeladler ist hier nicht gut
angekommen dass politisch beim public
viewing in leicester trifft man auch auf
fans die verständnis haben für die zwei
herzen in der brust viele nazi spieler
ich bin ziemlich klar begraben
zusammengespielt schützen ort
verschlagen möglich machen das ist eine
spielerisch und die mannschaft befragen
dann schwierig wenn nicht
nach der drei zu null niederlage am
sonntag katzenjammer beim fc besa
[Musik]
stellungsspiel fuß sagt und habe brutal
ist
da man jetzt sinnvoll ihnen ein
er springt mache jetzt etwas sagen auch
alles bucht wo vorsieht davon vorstand
somit das spiel organisiert aber für uns
und ich am freitag doch nachher mit dem
12 und ein bisschen sexy dort sind nur
für die fcb-spieler das bewusst werden
dass sie ja doch nie verstehen was du
alles braucht seit der gründung vor 26
jahren habe man im fcb sehr viel für die
integration der spieler getan
ich denke so ein verein öffnet die
andere perspektive was integration
anbelangt und sonst war sein verein
braucht damit man informationen nach und
wir machen es tue ihm im alltag leben
wie wie funktioniert mit tierischen
andere nationalitäten nicht nur mit der
spitze sind die andere nationalitäten
stets so wichtig sind mir hängt übrigens
nicht sehr sehr schöner erfolg so
marketingleiter er hat alle heime in der
umgebung art frage tops junge spieler
hat wo wenn druck da ist doch ich weiß
nicht ich finde das sehr verbindlichen
teil glaube nimmt bitte 39 waren also
das hat mit der situation store und mir
während ja unterstützt sind alle tür
offen für andere nervenzellen
natürlich meint der schweizer jetzt da
jetzt gerade die erste mannschaft mehr
hätte aber der junioren spitze halten
sie sich nicht komisch vorausgesagt
die integration geglückt doch wie geht
es weiter mit der nazi im stadion von
leicester wird es eine ehrenvolle eins
zu null niederlage gegen england geben
die schweizer fans sind zufrieden
die politik hat das feld zu gunsten des
fußballs wieder geräumt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch im stammlokal des fc besa in st
gallen fachsimpelt man wieder über tore
und taktik statt über doppeladler und
doppelbürger
[Musik]
zeit einen zu wort kommen zu lassen der
sich selber als halber bezeichnet
etretat slayer ist der sohn einer
schweizerin und eines albaners
sp-grossrat im kanton st gallen mitglied
der fachkommission migration und
integration
ich habe behauptet dass wenn
nationalmannschaft gegen den anspielen
dass das ist im konzept das der
politisch ist und dass der politische
klischees voran denn auch wieder
aufräumen
es gibt daher wunderschönen satz darüber
dass fußball einfach der az mit
friedlichen mitteln kann ich so
umschrieb es wird durchaus aggressiv
focus fragwürdige energie kanalisiert in
einem friedlichen rahmen ihnen ich war
aber nach der mannschaft ganz ehrlich
das relativ banal wenn sie essbar spiel
hintereinander gewinnt dann ist das land
wird es ernst
[Musik]